It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 170th episode today, Ruffians!
171!
BAU BAU!
I feel like it's such happy numbers.
171!
I don't know why, it reminds me of ice cream.
Like 31.
It's 171 flavors, Moco-chan!
That'll be fun.
Just bite down, Moco-chan!
You're gonna pick one flavor, huh?
And I'll stick to it!
BAU BAU!
Double BGM!
Why?
Is that better, Ruffians?
Is that better?
No?
Yeah?
Okay!
We'll figure it out later then!
BAU BAU!
Now that that mischief's solved, Moco-chan!
Out of 107 flavors of ice cream, what are you gonna have, huh?
You're just gonna have one flavor, huh?
Yeah.
Black licorice ice cream.
Maybe?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, it's a brand new week!
Thank you for joining us!
And for Ruffians who are here for the very first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays, once a week.
You know, so FUWAMOCO can get a bit more balanced in our lives!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Yeah!
Please take your de-
BAU BAU!
Please tweet your thoughts.
Not your tweets, please tweet your tweets.
With the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
There's some technical issues today, huh?
A bit.
Well, that's what happens sometimes when you wake up on a Monday morning, huh?
Technical issues.
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan, let's get started with the week, shall we?
More technical issues.
Huh?
What do you mean?
BAU BAU!
Well... Technically more issues, you know.
Huh?
Cuz... There's been another Pero sighting!
Where was he sitting now, Moco-chan?
Let's take a look.
Okay.
De-den!
Huh?
Uh, hi!
Hi.
Ludicrous?
Oh!
Looks like there's some nasty came across your shirt.
Hi.
But, I... Moco-chan.
I don't know.
If you think about it, maybe we're... Ruffians, you know.
Nobody's supposed to do that, right?
Look at a solar lunar eclipse?
Oh, you know, maybe Pero... Pero was just trying to protect you!
Right?
If you look at the lunar eclipse in your eyes, they burn into fire, right?
Isn't that a solar eclipse?
Huh?
Isn't a lunar eclipse and a solar eclipse not the same thing?
He wasn't protecting you.
One okie solo bag.
Both aren't safe.
Hi?
They're different!
They're similar, but different.
Just like FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians, I can tell you.
If you look at us, your eyes aren't gonna burn up.
I suppose not.
Let us know if...
BAU BAU!
Maybe this was a good Pero sighting.
Maybe it was bad.
But today I learned that there's a solar eclipse and a lunar eclipse and they are different.
A little dot.
A tiny dot.
It kind of looks like something on the left.
It's a dot.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, there's been a bunch of brand new things happening.
Lots of cool ones.
And just this last past week, we performed together with Ayame-senpai during her 7th anniversary D&D Live!
BAU BAU!
We performed a song called Mawari Setsugetsuka together with her.
You know it!
It's a legendary anime song!
But a very cheeky one.
A lot of tongue twisters.
Yeah, and it's so fast, so hard to sing.
That's really hard for Japanese people too, you know.
But we did our best!
A lot of tongue movement.
Yeah.
We practiced a lot a lot, and there was definitely a lot of frustration at times too, huh?
We are so happy together to be able to perform with Ayame-senpai!
And we are Ayame-senpai's first EN guest too!
It's kind of hard to believe.
BAU BAU!
I don't know, more than anything I was also surprised that Ayame-senpai hadn't sung this song yet.
Right!
I feel like it's just Ayame-senpai's song.
If I had to say my favorite part, it was the ha ha ha ha ha ha haiya!
Oh no, Moco-chan.
Lily's favorite part was... my waiting part.
Yeah.
That's the main part of the song, huh?
But if you didn't check it out yet, please go check it out on Anime-senpai's channel!
Yeah, we're able to dance with fans and everything too!
Very pretty!
And Anime-senpai has a new outfit too!
So you have to take a look!
But on the topic of 3D lives,
Just hours ago, Botan-senpai had her birthday 3D live!
It was amazing!
Botan-senpai, she said it was her first music live in 3 years!
3 years!
I can't believe it, but we were so so excited!
I love seeing Botan-senpai singing and dancing!
And we really love Botan-senpai's music too, so we couldn't leave!
But, uh...
We're a little bit busy.
We're at the studio.
We only got back until the last song.
Only to realize... Almost every single song she sung was a Visual Novels song!
From Visual Novels, Bishoujo Games songs!
Ruffians!
Why did you not let us know sooner?
We were so so happy!
So many fevers!
You should've let us know.
Yeah, it was amazing!
Nino Towaru Ryuu no Koi no Uta.
Nino-senpai did it before.
That's my song!
I say that!
Nino and Nobuta, let's go!
Let's go!
Yeah, and us Fudeho's here together with Hanata-senpai too.
Absolutely legendary!
Amazing.
Yeah.
I don't know, we definitely need to talk to Botan-senpai more about all of this.
Were you supposed to tell us about it?
Yes, you were.
You were supposed to.
Before FUWAMOCO stops what you're doing, go!
Right!
You were sleeping when it happened and I guess that's a good example.
You should have woken up!
No, the most important part is you're here now!
I should have woken up.
But you definitely need to go check it out and wish Botan-senpai a happy birthday!
I'm sleeping no doubt!
I was there together with Botan-senpai too, singing and dancing!
I'm happy.
Yeah, she did an amazing job.
Please go take a look at Advent!
Of course, Botan-senpai, she also just debuted a brand new original song too!
So go take a listen too, okay?
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday, Botan-senpai!
My favorite senpai of them all, Birthday-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Bye bye!
It was Ayame-senpai's 7th anniversary live.
It was Sora-senpai's 8th anniversary too.
It's been months going on!
And another big anniversary coming up.
It's Calli-senpai's 5th anniversary.
5th anniversary.
Morning Calliope.
hololive English and Myth is all turning 5 very soon here!
And Calli's here too!
She's celebrating with a very special dating show together with VRChat!
And there's gonna be a new outfit!
But also all of hololive will be there as guests too!
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited!
You know, Calli-senpai, she's so, so wonderful, so talented.
All of our senpai are.
Yeah, but you know, sometimes she can get very emotional, especially when it comes to, you know, things like this, so... I would never know what that is like, ever.
I'm sure you know it's gonna be a very special 5th anniversary celebration.
And a lot of fun too!
So we hope that you'll be there!
BAU BAU!
Off the topic of 3D comics, we have De-den!
A merch update for FUWAMOCO!
We are very happy to see lots of Ruffians suddenly without beds.
Because they're full with FUWAMOCO-dake!
Your bed has been taken over!
Look!
Ruffians!
No more room for you.
You're gonna have to sleep on the floor now.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you so much Ruffians for waiting a little bit longer than usual.
It took a little bit of time.
Yeah, there's some bumps along the road, but I'm happy to see our birthday match finally reaching you!
There's some Ruffians with some amazing Itabags going!
You know, the poshi keychain.
Yeah!
Now Ruffians, we can go easily with you wherever!
A bit more portable size!
Easier to fit in your photos maybe than the friends with you!
We're really cute!
Yeah, and also seeing our signed ticket cards added to your signs too!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
An update from FUWAMOCO too!
You know we had our 1 million celebration merch!
I paused!
I done writing!
We finished all the signatures!
It finished in a good while.
A little while ago.
Yeah, that's busy.
But now that means that maybe they'll be reaching you in mid-November?
Maybe.
Soon!
That's only like two months away.
A month and a half ish.
Are you waiting for a punch?
We can't wait for it to reach you!
Now!
We're already on sighting our second anniversary!
The paws are still going, Ruffians!
From one to another!
And the shirts look so cool!
I can't wait to see you wearing them, Ruffians!
It'll be perfect with the hat.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so so much, Ruffians!
You know, the FUWAMOCO collection's gonna get very very big this year.
Is it gonna be okay, Ruffians?
Maybe we'll have to get another shelf, huh?
We were just tidying up.
And now we're going... We need some shelf suggestions, I think, Ruffians.
Yeah.
Yeah, only two years?
Yeah!
Another house, another house.
Maybe a dog house.
What?
BAU BAU!
Thank you always, always.
Thank you!
P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P
No, Ruffians, you don't need that.
Because you know there was also the Pero Pushy too.
BAU BAU!
I mean, it is life-size, right?
Pretty much the same.
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians!
Just the other day, we're also on the official hololive channel.
Because there is a very special 3D program with brand new news!
About 6 of us.
And!
That the Blu-ray just released!
You can now pre-order it on the hololive shop!
Amazing, Ruffians.
It includes all stages and the creator stage.
That's over a hundred songs.
You know, I might know a bit what you're thinking.
I saw it, I went to it, you know.
I watched, I caught the streaming ticket.
It's just gonna be the same.
Maybe some angles will be fixed up and done.
We understand, you know.
That's what you would think.
But, we were really surprised.
Yeah.
Holofocus.
Ruffians, holofocus!
It's like an OSHI cam, but way better!
It's completely different!
Just off your OSHI, brand new angles, close-ups, everything!
Yeah.
Basically, every unit's song!
You can use the whole focus to take a look at your own OSHI!
And you know, it's not just a straight-on angle!
No.
The best angles have been hand-picked so that you can have the best place, the best place, the best perspective!
Watch your OSHI!
Of course, Alpha-san.
You put so much love into it, Ruffians!
It came in like... You know, all of us, we worked really, really hard to do the absolute best we could.
You know, so every time, Ruffians, I think sometimes, you know, you feel very passionate about your oshi, you want to see your oshi from many different angles and perspectives, and maybe sometimes you'll be like, THE CAMERAMAN!
WHAT'S THE CAMERAMAN DOING?!
WHAT THE HECK?!
Now,
You'll never feel like that again, we'll focus a lot.
So you know, if you want to watch Rebellions and... Ah!
I want to see Mococo hype up the crowd!
Right!
You can just see Moco-chan and be like... I don't want to see Moco-chan!
I want to see what everybody else is doing!
I want to see Biboo run across the stage from one side to the other in no time!
Right!
Almost bumping into everyone!
You know what?
Because of Holofocus, you can now see them!
So you know before, if you went to Sixpence, you saw it on the streaming!
Now you can experience it with the Blu-ray in a completely different way with Holofocus!
I'm sort of curious though, I wonder...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Who knows what it could have in it?
So please go check it out, FUWAMOCO!
And if you're interested in the stream, you see this.
Moco-chan!
I did it again.
I was trying to, you know, make an example of the adrenaline that, you know,
I'm gonna be like, I can't do it!
Look at my best attempt now!
I did it.
That was a pretty good attempt, Moco-chan.
Look at me standing there all silly like she's not gonna do it.
I am expecting my sister to fail.
Hai.
Yeah, I was like, okay, go ahead Moco-chan, go ahead and fail!
Hai!
Well, but there was a lot of silly moments together with Matsuri-senpai and Ririka-chu.
So, please go take a look too.
But, holofocus, you know, this means that, well, maybe we can live in a timeline that we're so lucky to get all for one.
No way.
I know.
Holofocus, maybe, could it be in the end?
Right!
Wouldn't that be nice?
We'll have to let them know how much you love the holofocus so they can look at it.
Wasn't that great?
Yeah.
Right?
No more worries about the camera man.
I know, right?
Yeah.
Why did the blue rain take so long for this?
This is why.
Holofocus.
It makes sense now.
Yeah.
I see, I see.
Right?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We also very synchronized and funny ways to doing the program, huh?
I don't know.
I did one silly backwards running jumping.
I don't know what that was.
I saw it, I was like what the heck?
I never move like that.
Why would we move like that?
I only went like that because I was petite.
And then I was like oh I gotta move back out of the way cause I'm gonna get Ririka's way.
You decided to do the same thing huh?
I don't know.
Should we have this kind of power?
That's a good question.
I don't know.
Okay, let's continue here!
BAU BAU!
Hi.
Hello!
Ruffians!
It's alright.
Yeah.
It's all... Uh-huh.
Ruffians!
I don't know why this is the case.
There seems to be some confusion about who tweeted this.
But, Ruffians, you should definitely, definitely know by now when Moco-chan, when she says she didn't do something, that means she's obviously the culprit, right?
That's never how it is.
Right?
Ha?
Yeah.
That's never how it is, okay?
Thank you.
Yes.
Uh, well.
It was a bit hot.
It made me a little bit more than normal.
I don't want things to be like this, Moco-chan.
Why don't we just remember for this tweet, huh?
Don't look proud like that!
I can't say anything.
It was just something that I tweeted on the way to the studio.
I mean, no.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
Ruffians!
You did amazing!
There's lots and lots of amazing art!
Hi!
Most of it is quote retweeted.
And we can't see them for some reason.
They aren't in the hashtag.
But, you know, there's lots of cute ones like this!
Cute!
Right?
Mococo is... Question mark?
You have an answer now, right?
Clear answer!
Cute!
Nice!
BAU BAU!
Mococo is BAU BAU!
Nice!
Cute!
Kawaii!
Mococo is right!
Always right.
But um... You know... I'm sorry.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
YouTube actually... Seems to think... I'm too sexy.
Guys, you know... Me upload is very very... Sexy.
Moshi-chan!
You know, for my birthday!
And uh...
YouTube seems like it doesn't want to show anyone it.
Yeah.
Did you see it?
Did you see it, Ruffians?
Did YouTube show you it?
Saw it?
Question mark?
Maybe that's a no.
You saw it?
You did!
You saw it!
Don't watch shorts, huh?
Why would you not watch this?
Huh?
Maybe send it to a friend then.
You could've asked the Lopez to send this to a friend, Moco-chan!
You can be like, Hi friend!
I have something very, very sexy to show you.
Here you go.
That sounds very suspicious, Moco-chan!
Suspicious YouTube link.
I don't know, Moco-chan.
I don't know what this means, but... It means one thing and one thing only.
You know the answer, right?
Mococo is... Too much for YouTube.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much so many creators!
Thank you!
Don't forget about Fuwawa.
BAU BAU!
On the topic of maybe making your heart beat a little faster than usual, FUWAMOCO!
We're actually going to be right back to the hololive official channel!
Because we're going to be on a special 3D program for Natsukyuu!
De-den!
How do I cover it up?
It hasn't quite ended!
We're not gonna let it end!
We did it and I know there's a big holo by the legs, but!
We're back!
We're part of the Natsukyuu!
We're ready to make your heart kyun-kyun a little bit, Ruffians!
This time it's a lot of firsts for us!
And we're on the official hololive channel and we're asked to participate in this program in Japanese, so we did our best!
It was rocking!
Yeah, but we really hope that in the future that maybe hololive EN on the EN channel we can have more programs like this too, right?
Well, you don't know what you're looking forward to yet, so... BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Let's check it out!
BAU BAU!
Aha!
That's more like it, yeah.
You don't have to look at FUWASENPAI anymore.
Today was a little bit silly to start off the day with.
Can you make it a little bit better?
Can you fix all the problems?
Can I?
You can fix all the problems, right?
I'm gonna try my best, Moco-chan.
I'll try.
I can't promise.
No promises, but... I'll try!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
Ah.
I got confused.
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
You know.
You know when it's night time and your body is aching.
I need rest!
I'm sleepy!
I can't do this anymore!
Yeah.
You know that.
You know what time it is then.
It is time to listen to what you're saying and go to sleep.
You know, close your eyes, get a good rest, get cozy, and come back again strong the next day in the morning!
Yeah!
Okay!
Yeah.
Time to sleep.
Maybe not right now.
Later.
You know, if you do that, you'll thank yourself.
Got it.
Every day.
For a whole week, okay?
Just try it!
Let's all power through and make this an amazing week all together!
BAU BAU!
There's a lot of Ruffians that just woke up, Moco-chan.
What could this mean?
I'm not saying go to sleep right now.
I said night time.
Like when the Ruffians, when you get home from your busy day, they're like, I wanna go to bed!
Listen to yourself.
Don't play Uma Musume.
Don't play Silksong.
Other Senpai.
Or... Members.
Go to bed!
But not right now, because it's a new week!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Let's take a look at some of our submissions from Ruffians!
Today we have today's Doggie of the Day!
And today's Doggie of the Day is... That!
It's...
Fluffy dog!
Oh, so pretty.
Up with the trends, you know.
Perfect eyelashes.
Yeah, flowers.
You know, also very fashionable.
Hanging around FUWAMOCO places with you two.
Yeah!
But I think we can tell Flower Dog's a very hard-working doggy of a day, huh?
Can probably
Carry stuff.
Yes.
Is flower dog an okay name?
Flower dog everyday?
Flower dog.
Flower dog?
Yeah.
Cute.
Moco-chan.
How does flower dog bow bow?
Wow!
Maybe the bark was kind of not working so well.
It's a warning sign.
Wow, you know, flower dogs are very hard worker.
He can carry lots of heavy flowers.
There's heavy flowers, right?
Heavy flowers!
You know, like the flowers that intertwine two people deeply in love.
Yes, flower dog, flower dog works hard to protect the love of all!
And very well behaved.
As a flower dog should be.
He'll probably carry a boulder.
A boulder.
Yeah.
Of love.
Yes.
BAU BAU!
He protects smiles too?
Yes.
Also love.
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
That sounds like it was a very long good nature walk.
Nice walk!
You know, it sort of looks like...
You know when people leave forgotten items along a path?
Ah, like when you're hiking and you're like, oh, there's a hat here, and then you put it up on like a marker?
Ah, someone lost their FUWAMOCO here.
You didn't leave us in the forest, did you?
You gotta hear a POPO coming from the trees.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
I'm sure we powered this Ruffian's walk.
Right, Moco-chan?
We didn't get lost.
We didn't get left behind.
Hope so.
Start of a horror game!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I'm glad you found a good one!
And look at all those leaves!
It's gonna be very, very pretty autumn leaves falling too.
It's still summer!
I have summer leaves.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Well, you know, we've talked about it a bit before, but we're very particular with the choreography for our songs, you know, especially our originals.
I think we really like fun choreography.
Maybe something that Ruffians can join in together.
Dance with us!
FUWAMOCO 2
Gotta get stronger!
Ruffians, it's time for us to go swimming soon.
BAU BAU!
We have the swimsuits now, so pull them Moc-tan.
Thank you so much for all your submissions, Ruffians!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together.
Here with you, Ruffians!
Temporarily, once a week.
But we're always looking forward to your doggy of a days!
Seeing your walks that you're going on, especially with maybe new autumn leaves.
Seeing your questions.
Such good questions, Ruffians!
Don't forget to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
And we have another stream coming up very shortly!
We're gonna be playing Donkey Kong Country 2!
Wow, we're playing it on this nest?
This nest does not have save states.
We made a mistake.
We are out of lives.
We got too excited after beating the last boss and we didn't save.
And now we're in a little bit of a pinch.
But!
I can see the light at the end of the tunnel.
I think we can get through Castle Crush.
We are crushed in a castle.
We're getting better at this, Ruffians!
We can do it, okay!
BAU BAU!
Snackcorn is currently off.
Snackcorn has taken a vacation.
Yes.
And we'll be back just in time for more Donkey Kong Country 2!
Please help us, Ruffians!
I'm feeling confident.
Moco-chan, how are you feeling?
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ashin!
BAU BAU!
Dr. Viper.
Renyu.
BAU BAU!
Kanda Kai.
Zekko.
BAU BAU!
Tomato House.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!